i'm audrey
princess audrey
sleeping beauty's daughter we don't mean
to bother you sleeping beauty but we're
a little concerned and confused your
daughter audrey nearly destroyed her
enemies in auradon in descendants 3 but
you were nowhere to be found your mom
leo was there and she even patched
things up with mal so we just want to
know why you weren't by your daughter's
bedside when haiti saved her life audrey
could have used the support
we probably weren't the only ones who
wanted to see princess aurora into
sentence 3. luckily audrey's mom popped
up in a popular tv series so we finally
know what she looks like and whether or
not she looks like audrey keep watching
to see what the missing parents from
descendants 3 really look like no
i don't hate my mother
dizzy and drizzella dizzy's grandmother
lady tremaine might be a total villain
but her daughter's anastasia and
drizella aren't exactly the conniving
type they just do what they're told we
never catch a glimpse of dizzy's mom in
descendants 2 and 3 but we do get to see
her in once upon a time funny enough
anna cathcart actually played the
teenage version of druzella on the show
um and ursula uma is one of our favorite
vks and she's the daughter of ursula
while we don't get to see the sea witch
in descendants 2 we do catch a glimpse
of her long tentacles
shut your clams mom
these dishes ain't gonna wash themselves
we know that actress whoopi goldberg
voiced ursula in the disney channel
movie however we get to see a better
look at ursula in once upon a time chad
cinderella and prince charming in 2015
disney released the live-action remake
of cinderella actress lily james
portrayed cinderella while actor richard
madden played prince charming this movie
told the tale of how cinderella and
charming fell in love and thanks to the
descendants franchise we know that they
eventually had a son named chad lonnie
and mulan
loni is a brave and talented fighter who
never backs down from a fight and she
gets that from her warrior parents mulan
and lee shang the live-action remake of
mulan is hitting the big screen on march
25th 2020 and we're super excited we'll
get to see the real-life version of
lonnie's mother mulan doug and dopey
doug has got to be the nicest ak in
auradon he never had a problem with the
vks attending auradon prep hi guys i'm
dopey sun as in dopey doc bashful happy
grumpy sleepy and he made everyone feel
welcomed he probably gets this from his
dad dopey who once risked everything by
letting a stranger move into his home we
never get to see doug's dad in the
descendants movies but he does pop up
and once upon a time ally and alice ally
is a character who doesn't appear in the
actual descendants movies however ali is
a popular ak when it comes to the
animated short series descendants wicked
world we wish ally could have made it
into d3 it would have been super cool to
see ally and alice standing side by side
luckily we know exactly what alice looks
like thanks to the live action alice in
wonderland movies audrey aurora and
phillip much like dizzy we never get to
see audrey's parents in d3 but we do get
to meet her grandmother
our family status gone queen leah is a
real piece of work but she starts to
loosen up by the end of the three quill
we never get to see princess aurora or
prince philip which is a total bummer
but once again we get to meet the
younger versions of audrey's parents in
once upon a time evie and the evil queen
evie and the evil queen might have their
differences but they connect over beauty
and fashion we get to see what evie's
mom looks like in the first descendants
film but it's hard to see the
resemblance and once upon a time we get
to meet a very different version of the
evil queen actress lana perea portrays
evie's soon-to-be mother on the show
ruby insulin and rapunzel much like ally
ruby and insulin don't appear throughout
the descendants franchise but they are
leading characters in the descendants
wicked world miniseries rapunzel is one
of the most adored disney princesses of
all time so we would have loved to see
her and her kids appear in descendants
3. we know what rapunzel looks like as a
cartoon and thanks to once upon a time
we now know what she looks like in human
form gill and gaston gill is the
furthest thing away from being a villain
he just wants to make friends go on
adventures and try some cool new
foods rocks giant fish
you're probably used to grabbing lunch
off of a bush but his dad gaston isn't
the chummy type gill hardly ever
mentions his father and after watching
the 2017 live-action remake of beauty
and the beast we finally know why gaston
is super pompous and self-involved jay
and jafar we know what jafar looks like
thanks to the descendants franchise but
we were curious to see what he looked
like when he was younger jay's dad can
be seen in the 2019 live-action remake
of disney's aladdin he's portrayed by
actor marwan kenzari malin maleficent in
2015 kristen chenoweth took the stage to
portray mao's mother maleficent in the
first descendants film
it's all about you and me baby do you
enjoy watching innocent people suffer
but we haven't seen her since mal
transformed her into a lizard but we get
to see younger versions of maleficent
and ursula battling it out on the
episode of once upon a time harry and
captain hook the cartoon version of
captain hook was pretty evil and
outdated thankfully once upon a time
brought us a captain hook that does his
son harry a lot of justice both father
and son are gifted in the looks
department and they're both a lot nicer
than they pretend to be who is your
favorite child parent duo tell us in the
comments hit that subscribe button and
give this video a big thumbs up thanks
for watching we'll see you again soon
[Music]